um so welcome everyone to the uh the
second lecture in our series on pcb
theorems so today we're very happy to
have donna moskowitz from the university
of texas at austin
an expert on pcp theorems in their
applications to tell us how to prove a
weak version of pcp theory
hey thank you so much joe um
okay so so i will show um a proof of a
weak pcp theorem
uh a proof that will hopefully more or
less fit in
in one hour um i'll try to do it the the
traditional way
questions and answers and do the
traditional way this time
so after i discuss something i just
pause for
questions and and try to answer um
the ones that that accumulated um
okay so so elite uh uh presented the pcp
theorem
yesterday um so pcp means for
ballistically checkable proofs
um and it has many many different
formulations
um and the formulation that she gave
was as follows um you can take a graph
any graph g and you can in polynomial
time
convert it into a graph
g tilde and such that
if g
if
um
if
g is
if g is three colorable
three color bro then um
so is g field
and meanwhile if jeez is not
recordable
detailed is found
from a three-color ball
in the sense that
for every coloring of the vertices
at least
0.01 fraction of edges
monochromatic so they weakness that this
is not
a good coloring
okay um if the graph is not
recordable it just means that for every
coloring there exists
an edge that is that is not followed
right
and suddenly here for g tilde
uh not only there exists one edge there
exists
many many edges and so constant fraction
of the edges are monochromatic
and in this in this transformation from
g
to gt in this polynomial for normal time
it means in particular that that we
consider g
tildes that are polynomial size um
no one knows how to efficiently figure
out whether g is
equal or not and yet we have this
transformation
that that makes um the fact that the
graph is not recordable
manifested in in a in a very large way
okay
so so um 4g
you're given a coloring you really have
to go over the intel coloring to check
it and for details
you don't need to to go over the entire
coloring
it's enough to pick a random edge
and check if if it's good check if it's
it's about
um multichromatic by chromatic
um and and if it's good
then you're reasonably likely that we're
in the in the first
case of detail this liquidable and not
in the second
case and of course you can repeat this
this test many times right repeat it
like 100 or thousand times
and and you can get pretty much sure
that this will probably in the in the
writing they're all
uh followed right all those random edges
then then you get pretty sure
that you're in the the horrible case
not in the second case okay
so this is this is this amazing theorem
and
more generally what's happening here is
that we have global property and the
global property here
is is g is a three-color ball
so this is a property that is it's quite
you have to given a coloring you have to
go and check everything
and then you somehow are able to test it
with a local test
okay so so the local test here is like
peak
random
edge in
gt and and check okay
now there are many different
formulations of the pcp theorem many
different pcp theorems
and and different pcp theorems consider
different global properties and and also
different local tests and accordingly
they they achieve um different
parameters
um so we can start with talking about
the global properties also here
g is recolorable but but more generally
eric mentioned
it's every it's every property of the
form
there exists some solution for your
input
such that it satisfies something
that that can be checked in polynomial
time
okay so so anything that can be
formulated like that
this is what we call mp languages uh
you can choose your global property
right so so g is the color rule there
exists a coloring such that
all the edges are colored right
uh but but you can pick anything right
your input
can be a number n and your y
can be um some some
possible mathematical proof and a y can
check
whether this this is a valid proof of
size
n to the remaining hypothesis right so
so this is also applicable if someone
comes to you and says i found
appropriate my hypothesis
with maybe a computer and and the proof
is
is many terabytes and you want to check
it
and and kind of you don't know how to go
about checking the the original proof
it's so large to even just store
um but suddenly with the specific
theorem if only this person wrote
the proof applies transformation you can
now test it in a in a
local way and
and here we right here it was uh
coloring um with gt
but but in general we can try to have
all kinds of local tests and
local tests can differ in in what we
call the number of queries
or the number of proof locations that we
consider
here it's two but it doesn't have to be
two it can be three or four or ten or
maybe even more though usually two is
enough
um it can can be different in what we
call the
the alphabet which here is the number of
colors
and it's three but the alphabet can be
larger
and um and it can differ in which
predicate
you test so here it's uh whether
the edge is uh by chromatic or not
but but it could be any any predicate
you want
on those
queries that you make the issue is that
it's local the issue is that
we look at a small number of um
of places in the in this transformed um
graph or transformed input okay so i see
a question
can the pcp theorem itself be formulated
in
p language um
yes i think this is something that that
appealed uh
questions of the people i'll try to
answer it i'm not sure that i understand
it right but but
uh yes in particular
uh g right here we're talking about the
sleep coloring problem
right so in particular here we're
talking about an np
language and and this spoof
which is a free coloring here
right is also legitimate
np proof okay
so
yes right so so so we start with an np
um with an np poverty here
and we end up with an np property here
but it's a much more robust
uh property right here it's enough to
check
randomly small local tests
uh and and still know uh whether this
big global property holds or not with
good probability
okay so i hope that this answers the the
question
if there are any other questions
let me let me say one more thing that
that people asked yesterday
um what what's the point would they say
0.001
right it's obviously it's arbitrary but
but um
but you couldn't put here you know
something much much larger right um
when you talk about recoloring so so
once you
you decide on what your number of
queries and what's your alphabet and
what you'll break it um
there is some number that that you can
you can put here
that is the the right number so so for
example for free coloring
uh if i just picked my my coloring
completely at random right so so each
vertex
i assigned a random following um
then then with probability the
probability that
if i look at one edge that the edge is
not
followed right it's just one third okay
so it's very every every graph basically
has a
has a coloring that with with one third
uh here so so i mean i can't prove this
for
something better than that okay
but um but yeah if you want to put here
something
very very close to one you can but then
the number of queries the alphabet and
the predicate should be
it should be accordingly and and the
amazing thing is that you keep that you
can keep the number of queries too
and in fun you increase the alphabet if
this is epsilon maybe the alphabet needs
to be like one of the left
or something but but um the predicate
needs to be
like a different pertinent recorder
um but but you can actually achieve here
whatever
the the l probability can be extremely
extremely small even with just
with just two queries in the local test
okay so let me see what new questions i
got um
are the monochromatic edges in gtilled
evenly distributed among the edges of
the graph
so so what i told you it's a 0.01
fraction
right so you pick a uniform edge and
and right you have this this constant
probability to
to get it um yeah and
and you can pull all kinds of feelings
that that show that
right you can do all kinds of
transformations that can show
various even distribution of
of the bed of the bed edges um
right so different different pcp terms
also differ in
in you know you can get all kinds of
extra properties
on on on properties of the
of the graph like degree or properties
of the
you know where the bed edges are they
support it on on
almost on most vertices and so on
um yeah so you can assume
even distribution um
yeah i'll explain i right now i only
stated the normal pcp theorem
i can actually even explain it now so so
so
the weakness would be that i won't show
a
polynomial transformation um
what i'll show is that i can generate
a random edge here uh within polynomial
time
okay the graph itself that i'll
construct today
is going to be of exponential size in in
g
but i'll be able to pick a random edge
from gt
um
in polynomial time okay so so this is
not what permits
we can actually prove what's what's
promised um
but um but right i'm trying to do
something that can fit in an hour
okay um if this
didn't answer the question
[Music]
um yeah okay hopefully
question yeah right i
answer the question of uh for tweak it's
not going to be a pretty normal time
time transformation today just
random edge is going to be generated
good okay so hopefully um
we know what what we'll try to prove
i want to say something more about what
i'll try to prove
um
so so as i said you can change the
global property and
the local tests and different pcp
theorems differ in different choices of
the global poverty and the local test
um the choice of the global property
yeah so this is just a kind of a matter
of convenience the kind of equivalence
between different global properties at
least up to polynomial time
computations this is the magnificent
theorem theory of
anti-completeness that we have in
theoretical computer science
the the specific global property that
i'm going to consider
both as globalization is local is a
quadratic equations
quadratic
of over um
zero one so so what i mean is is um
two okay so so the computational problem
i'm going to consider
um so you're given a bunch of of
quadratic equations so so
polynomials of degree at most two things
like
um x1 times x 2
plus x 2 times
x 3 plus you know maybe x 1
plus x 5 and so on and so on
plus 1 equals 0 right so so i'm given
a bunch of equations like that
and and i'm trying to find the solution
so an assignment of zero one
right so everything is more true
right that's why i never have x1 squared
because x1 squared is just
x1 um i never have minus right because
minus is plus
um right so i walk over over
two i have n variables x 1 to x n
and i have a bunch of of equations like
this of the degree at most
two and i'm trying to figure out whether
they have a solution
so so this is the the problem that that
i'll use
[Music]
and what i'm going to show is i start
with this system of
of quadratic equations like this and i'm
going to
transform it to this squiggly distilled
system of equations and the thing is
that here
each equation
depends on
three variables
okay so so for for the initial
um the initial system of
quadratic equations the equations can
depend
each one can depend maybe on all
variables or many of the variables
and and in the new system each equation
is
right as a spouse system so each
equation only depends on three
uh variables of three beats which is
the minimum and and and as i said
so so um the transformation that i'm
going to define is not going to be
polynomial
in fact right this is the weak
this e tilt is going to be huge it's
going to be exponential in the size of e
but but each
equation will be generated random
equation will be generated in time
okay so um
[Music]
we'll show
so this is the week aspect
we'll show how to generate
an equation
in it in polynomial time
and instead of
not logarithmic time and
and and if you actually want ethel to be
the same
to be polynomial size you really need to
be able to
to generate it in in all the log n time
order log
e time and
this one i won't be able to do with the
construction i'll show you today
but but what i'll show is again those
two
bullet points if e
is is uh what we call satisfiable
so there exists some x some
assignment to the variables that
satisfies each and every equation
then also utility satisfiable
fully
whereas if he is not satisfiable
then it is
satisfiable
that is
for every assignment
assignment to x1 and x2 xn
and at least
0.01 fraction
of equations of force
and and by kind of standard ideas of
completeness you could have
i i mean i'll show you this theorem but
you could have
cast it in the language of pre-coloring
like
like you know it's uh formulation
maybe with some loss to parameters
let's see what what are my questions
each equation in each field
is generated in polynomial time but it
in itself takes exponential time to
generate because they're exponential
equations that's
true um
good polynomials that's polynomials
here it fails to polynomial in the
number of variables
so the log of number of variables wait
so polynomial
[Music]
where did they use polynomial in the
it's it's polynomial time in the size
of e so i assume that they start with
the system of equations with n
variables and say all the n equations
um and now uh
i can generate each equation in
polynomial hopefully this answers the
question uh
is there any relation between the
satisfying solutions of
e and e t yes so what we'll show is that
we can start
with so we if we start with a satisfying
solution for e
we can use it
in cody to get a satisfying solution uh
to ep and vice versa if you have
a solution to ethel that satisfies
many a huge number of the equations then
we can construct from it
solution that fully satisfies e all the
folks i'll show you how constructive
um more questions yeah i think that i
answered
the question
okay can detailed
http be allowed to satisfy at least 0.99
fraction of edges instead of being
a sleep collarable so so this is what
what i said in the previous slide
um
uh so free coloring was
some choice aesthetic choice and
in here it will be more convenient for
me to work with
with quadratic equations so this is what
i'll do
um and and you can move
from quadratic equations to coloring
from following
quadratic equations so this is the nice
theory of energy completeness
not transformations between two if you
don't care about what happens to the
factor
it's quite easy to
um to move between the two
okay good so hopefully now i
will all show what we are going to do
today
um in the in the
i guess a bit more than half an hour
okay good um so so
let's start a new whiteboard okay
so i'm just i'm just going to jump to it
and show
you the the construction um
let me say a few more things before i do
that um
so i'll show you quite a quite simple
construction
um it gives you some flavor for the
actual poop of the pcp theorem but to
actually prove the pcp ethereum you need
to work
much much harder this is one thing
um there are two
more reasons to show you this simple
construction
one is that the simple construction that
actually applications of
pcp like in practice uh to verify
things quickly and right you can find it
on
you know mozilla and and and you know
people try to put it in blockchains and
stuff um
so so so often what's used in practice
is actually this simple construction
that i'll show you
um and and the other thing is that each
and every
proof of the pcp theorem actually has
inside of it either the construction i
show you all
related construction okay so i'm not
showing you some
something that is unrelated to anything
it's actually
essentially inside each and every pcp
construction
um see that there are more questions
um is the actual construction of italian
current or is the mapping from e to e
tealing point um
the fact that there is a mapping from e
to e tilde is is the pcp theorem
um i will show you the construction
i think there is a lot to to learn from
it uh and it gives you kind of a feel
for
whether um or how this can be
true okay but the piece
right the pcb theorem says something
quite extraordinary that
i mean someone has a huge proof
poseidon hypothesis um they can write it
in a different format and suddenly you
will be able to
to check it probabilistically by by
looking only at a few bits in the proof
right this is this is this crazy
crazy statement and then it's unclear
that it can be true and
and hopefully you'll get a feel for why
how it could be true
on this lecture um
[Music]
so er er so let's let's look at the
construction
so so here is the construction
and okay so so i assume
that the e the the system i started with
of linear equations so so we
okay right we start with
e and i assume on on the variables of x1
through xn
and with equations
e1 equals zero
until em equals zero
okay and without loss of generality and
the same
magnitude um and and now i want to
define for you
ethel okay so
itill has a variable
for every
quadratic
polynomial q
that takes 0 1 to the n
and gives
0 1. okay so here quadratic means degree
at most two so it can be linear it can
be
constants are not very interesting but
uh
okay so so every quadratic polynomial
and
let me just say a quadratic polynomial
is given by
um is is given by
this coefficient right so qx equals
sum qij xi x j
and and it's possible let's let's define
that x 0
is defined to be 1 so this encapsulates
also the
the linear functions
um okay
um so so for every quadratic polynomial
i'm going to have a variable right so so
you already see that that the
e tilde is huge with respect to e right
because the number of quadratic
polynomials
this is like 2 to the n squared um
[Music]
okay but but fine i can generate each
one in one
time um and and i'm going to
denote it
q x and
and what i mean is that what i want this
variable to be assigned
is you know there is x that is supposed
to be the satisfying assignment to e
and what i'll ask the the the prover
right is is take this x a a good
assignment for
for e and evaluate q
on this x that you have in mind
okay so so it's supposed to be
q of x for some x because
what approval can do is completely
ignore what i'm what i ask him to do or
how to do and and give me any
assignment to to qx but i remember i put
it in quote
to remember that this is what i expected
to be there and
the quote mean that maybe this is not
what's going to be there
so this is this is a notation that that
i find
useful okay so so these are the
variables
uh in in ethics
okay so now i need to define for you
uh the equations and and what i'll do is
i'll just show you how to pick
a random equation in
in in et okay so p
and random
equation
equation in it
by doing the following procedure
so so i'm actually going to have like
three four types of
of equations um and
the first type so so this is with
probability
uh quarter i i do the following
i'm going to pick linear
l1 and l2 from 01
to the n to 0 1
and i'm going to check the the linear uh
polynomials right i said that quadratic
polynomials for male
or any polynomials of the great most so
in particular all the linear
uh polynomials and so the little
polynomials are
linear so i would expect
l1 of x plus
l2 of x to be
l1 plus l2 of x
right i mean if the what approval
actually did
if the assignment is actually you know
you have your x and you you
give each polynomial each l it
just gets l of x then indeed this this
this equality holds so let me test that
this happens
okay um
if there are any questions
um the second test
again with probability everything is
going to happen with probability of
culture
um so we do the same thing also the
family of quadratic polynomials is
linear so
i'm going to do the same thing big
quadratic
and q1 and q2
um
and i'm going to check the same right
q1x
plus q2a
equals q1 and plus q2
i mean maybe someone might wonder why do
i need both one and two
because obviously two subsumes one
but the issue is that when you pick
quadratic polynomials
most of the time you don't pick linear
polynomials because there are many more
higher degree than the linear and kind
of one guarantees
that there will be good properties for
those linear polynomials
um and two just we're guarantee
something for
for the three two polynomials
um so so this is my second test
um with probability encoder
and i'm going to now i'm going to check
the relation between
the queues and errors uh i'm going to
pick linear
l1 and 2 but now i'm going to check
that l1 x
times and 2x
equals l1 times
l2 x so finally i
do this right on the right hand side i
have
i have a quadratic polynomial on the
left hand side i have the multiplication
of two linear polynomials so kind of
compel the consistency between the
linear and the quadratic
polynomials right and obviously
if everything if there's no quotes
then then everything should hold so it
makes sense to check it
when there are quotes and finally
so notice that somehow what i'm trying
to do is i'm i'm trying to
make sure that the assignment to the
variables of ethils
looks indeed like what it's supposed to
be like like q of x
right so so every q is assigned
the valuation of q on on the
on this good solution right so i'm
trying to
to to force the assignment to actually
resemble
um the the intended assignment
and i haven't checked at all any of the
equations
in in e so this is what i'll try to do
now
so again with probability a quarter
um i'm going to pick um so i'm going to
pick two things i'm going to pick
a one to two rm zero one
and i'm going to pick a quadratic
q and i'm going to check
so i'm going to look at the linear
combination
r i e i um
right so so all my eyes right so these
are the equations from e
the original equations that actually
care about
oh wow you can see the the bottom of my
screen for some reason
um
right this is okay let me
i can try to write it on the side i did
not expect that you won't be able to so
i can see up to and including the bit
that says sum of r i and e i
oh you can see i don't know if there's
anything below that that's what i can
see
oh because i i cannot see you know on my
screen
uh i can only speak for myself
so let me let me use yeah on on on the
ipad
right i can actually there is i have
another line too
right let me use it uh so i'm going to
look at this
you know random linear combination of of
the
my equations from e and i'm going to
look at this
class skew right so this is some
quadratic polynomial and
and right which which i want to to
evaluate
on on on x
and and i'm going to make sure so so
remember
that i assume without loss of reality
that all my equations of e1 equals 0 e2
equals 0 and so on and so on
so really so so this linear combination
is supposed to be 0
if i actually have an assignment that
satisfies all the equations
so so this is supposed to be qx so let
me check that
okay so now let me answer questions how
to randomly pick
some equations that satisfy certain
properties
i don't understand right i just defined
for you
how to pick a random equation so with
obviously a quarter you do what's in one
with obviously equal to what's in two so
right each one of them
is an equation on its mostly variables
in my system
okay so i just defined for you
everything
um
i'm not going to ask you can i ask you a
question
sure please i thought you wanted to make
the new equation
sparse so one two and three are sparse
but the fourth one seems to involve just
as many variables as there are equations
in the original no it involves only two
variables right notice i thought that
each ei
would have been its own variable in your
name yeah yeah
there are at least m variables in this
equation right wait
each ei is its own variable however also
the linear combination of all the e i's
plus q
is also its own variable okay so i think
maybe a point of confusion for some
people because i've also had some chats
is that when you write a polynomial in
quotes it's not really the polynomial
it's the input variable to the details
to the equation detailed right so so so
so e tilde
so everything is one variable every
quadratic polynomial
and this i it by this
and it's just the name of the variable
right the variable is
getting a bit the bit can be anything
but what i expect i i do this because i
want to say
i expect this variable to be assigned
the quadratic polynomial evaluated
on on on the the good x
that that that's supposed to exist
great thanks okay we have more questions
what does l1 plus l2 x means it seems to
me that l1 plus l2 x equals
yeah again so so
all the equations i i wrote down are
equations that without the quotes
obviously hold but the issue
is that when i put the quote this is
just the name of the variable that is
supposed to be assigned
um this so and the variable could be
assigned anything
right um
so so with the quotes i mean
it's not clear but but hopefully what
i'll show is that if it holds with good
probability with high probability then
then my assignment actually can be
decoded to a good assignment for
e um
okay how does the variable in it yield
depends on the input x
though so
let me uh i understand there is one
variable for which one quadratic but is
there
also one for each assignment to the
variables no no
so we take e and
hopefully he e has one assignment to the
x's
that satisfies all the equations it may
have more right but
it should have at least right if we're
in the the situation where there is a
solution to e
then there exists some x that
that satisfies all the equations so
what i'm going to ask
the assignment to itil to be is you know
fix this x
and answer about this particular x okay
we don't answer about every possible
assignment
to the variables we answer about this
one assignment that is supposed to be
satisfying to to
to e which in the good case exists
in the bad case there is no such thing
right um
okay is the intuition for doing each
check with probability a
quarter that this effectively checks all
four conditions simultaneously
very much so this is exactly the what
we're trying to
to do right so so if i have a check
that i do everything with probability in
one quarter and i know that this test
except with extremely high probability
over development plus one in particular
each one of the four
except with very high probability and
this is what i'll use
yes good um
[Music]
yes any other questions
okay good so this is the construction
okay so so if you
if you're happy with the weak pcp
theorem
um this is this is the entire
transformation this is
pretty it's pretty amazing
um what i'm going to do in the next
15 minutes is explain to you how you
analyze
this construction
let's let me start a new whiteboard
okay so so that
um and and of course i'm i'm
going to not do it like all the way
but hopefully you will come out of it
knowing what's how you analyze it why is
the last equation some i
i plus q q and not just some
we'll we'll talk about that get to it
it's a good question um
no okay i i can answer so
i don't know if i can go back to um
so so it was the last question
which is why in the fourth in the fourth
test
why do i need this extra q um
and and the issue is that i don't
control the ease
right there is arbitrary equations
and then you know iei is a random linear
combination of them but but also the
combination is it's a it's a very small
portion of
of all my quadratic equations so
we'll see this i mean it's possible that
the assignment
for just this linear combination sigma
r i e i it's possible that this
assignment
is completely wrong so to show to show
that this equals zero i mean the
the the the may achieve that
without any kind of consistency with
some global assignment
um and that's why i have the cue to to
kind of cue is completely random
on a random quadratic i'll show that it
behaves well and
okay let's uh let's let's let's see it
in the
on the next slide um
when right we'll see the analysis and
then
we'll discuss all those things okay
so analysis
okay so the the kind of the bulk of the
proof
and also uh the one thing i won't have
time to
um to show you in full is what we call
linearity testing
um so linearity testing is exactly this
test one right so so l one x
plus l two x
is supposed to be l one plus l two
x okay so this is what i call linearity
testing they do it for random linear
functions l1 and l2
and and what i'll show is that if
test one which is which is this
right um passes
with probability at least 1 minus delta
delta think of it as a very small
constant
0.001 um
then um
there exists
x in 0 1
to the n and such that
in for at least
one minus delta a fraction
of the s
we have m
lx we actually equal
lx
okay
so right so before i ask the the the
provers to
the ask that the assignment to to give
me supposedly
the evaluations of all quadratic no or
or linear
functions on on some x
but but they didn't know that they did
it and and in this part we're saying
yeah but if we check this test one and
it passes with high probability it means
that there exists an x
such that they had to answer a falling
okay um
then we we fix this this x so this is
this is kind of the bulk of the of the
proof kind of
why if you have those those um
those local tests right l1 plus l2
equals l1 plus l2
white actually corresponds to a global
um
linear function and
i know of two proofs for that one
is that this is one of the easiest
proofs you can get with with fourier
analysis
um if you just write everything in
fourier
um right you can think of this test as
checking the correlation of
function with a convolution of the
function with itself
um and and you end up just getting there
the sum of the
the cubes of the fourier coefficients
and each coefficient correspond to a
different
x and if the sum of the cube is is large
then there must be a dominant
x um right so
for those of you who know fourier
analysis
i mean this is very easy um
and and and also you can just pull one
right in an elementary way and
[Music]
yeah so so right so what would you you
would say is
is yeah i don't know if i
maybe you can you can prove it
elementary and not let's not
actually do the proof right now um
because i'm running out of time um
but but in a way maybe this is the kind
of the the bulk of the
of the portal um
okay if i have time in the end i'm happy
to to answer questions about
about linearity testing
so this is the first thing uh so so this
this is the
kind of for the one thing with the one
part of the test um the the second
is is uh again linearity testing
similarly right we do this test not just
for the
the linear functions but also for the
cues and
in um right because of test two
and if test two
passes so test2 was q1 plus q2
equals q1 plus k2
passes with probability very large
probability
then there exists um
now it's going to be z in 0 1
squared such that
for at least 1 minus delta fraction
q
and we have
qx equals
um let's suppose q is some q i j
xixj this is
some qij
said ij okay so we can also
deduce linear structure on the queue
because we also do this linearity test
on the on the
so this is for some z
and 0 1 to the n squared
okay so so it's the same it's
application of the
the same lemma once applied on on the
other one
right out of different dimensions and
versus n squared
but otherwise it's exactly the same
so so now let's let's go over the third
the third test so so this is what's
called revolves
uh test in
so so so the claim is if
additionally two one and two
and test three passes
with probability at least one minus
delta and
let me remind you that test three is the
one that checks
um that l1 times l2
equals l1 times
m2
so if this has a check consistency
between the linear functions and the
quadratic functions if this process was
probably one minus delta
then in fact we we have
with probability at least one minus
then this probability is this one minus
order delta we actually have that q
x equals
q i j x i x
j right so so a conclusion similar to
what we had
for one for one we had it for linear
functions
now we can get it for the quadratic
functions of q x
actually behaves like q i j x i x j
for the x that we fixed in
one part of this analysis
uh this this actually happens for most
q x's okay
um okay so
i can actually explain the proof of
this this is quite easy
um so so what we have
from
okay so so what we have from
from 2 is i have this matrix
zij that that i know corresponds to
the q's and and the question is
whether this matrix actually equals
the matrix x i x j
uh and if it's it equals then then
exactly i get
um this uh q
behaving the way it's supposed to behave
i see a question
is the pcp algorithm practical algorithm
that could be used in settings such as
automated verification um
yes it actually is used in
in verification
the issue is um
you know what maybe i'll let me return
to this
when we do the summary in the end um
and let's first finish the the analysis
in two checking the delta proportion of
the one to the n squared requires still
exponential time
right if so white helps um
again right so this is a weak pcb
theorem
e tilde is of exponential size
okay so yes
uh however to actually generate an
equation
you can do it in polynomial time if
you're able to access
bits of the of this huge exponential
size pools
and again if you have random access to
them you can just
you can just check and put in real time
but yeah it's an exposure size
contraption that's why it's weak that's
why i'm not proving the full
pcb here and um
okay yeah and i'll return to you know
applications uh
okay so so so in three all we're trying
to do is
show that the z i j matrix is the same
as the x i times
x j matrix and if it is then then three
follows from two okay but but let's
remember what test three does so you can
think of test three
as taking right here um
right we take l1 and l2 you can think of
l1 and l2
is think of them as vectors right put
the coefficients
of l1 and the coefficients of l2 as
vectors right each of them these are
matrices that are m by n
and in each l each linear function has n
coefficients
and so really what we're doing in test
three
is is checking this
equality this is what test query is all
about
and um one can see that if
uh z i j is different than x i x j
then with uh uh right
you're going to have here um they're
going to be different uh
with with probably half um
and they're not going to be the same
with probably the cluster one
okay so this is this is the proof
um so this is the the
third portion and now finally the fourth
portion and i i remember but i still oh
this
this uh answer for why
well i think this will cue um
in the end and then hopefully you'll get
your answer here so this is what we call
self-correction
so so let's let's talk about about our
situation
in this point of the analysis so we
asked
the assignment to ethics to actually
evaluate each and every question
putting on your own this good ex
solution for you and and because all
those
one to three tests happen with high
probability
i now know that i picked some x in in
already in step one
and and i know that when i look at qx
with
with the the quotation marks
uh i actually get q of x
without quotation marks for most x's
if almost sorry for most cues okay so
this is what we achieved so far
okay but this is true for most skills
this is true for one minus
order delta of q's it's not true for
every single cube
okay so if i pick a random q with high
probability
quotation qx equals qx
but if i look at any particular uh
quadratic form
this may not be the case and the issue
is that some e
i i is
is uh uh it's very specific
quadratic form right ei are my equations
from
from e and i are just like random
coefficients zero one coefficients
so this is a specific um
quadratic form i cannot rely on
on this being being what it's supposed
to be
so here is here is the trick so this is
what we
what we call um uh
subcollection instead of looking at this
i'm looking at this plus q
right in and and i'm looking at this
entire quadratic form
and now i just because of this q i made
this
quadratic form it's just a random
quadratic form so with high probability
this is going to be equal so with
probability
1 minus omega of delta
this is actually equals to
uh sum e i r i plus q
of x
right this is what i achieved in one two
three
and and now i check right so this is
test four
i check whether this equals qx and and
again
with with with high probability this
equals to qx
this is what i achieved in one plus
three and the conclusion from both of
those things
being equal is that the sum
e i l i actually equals
of x actually equals
zero i don't know i mean i can't see it
on the screen
i can see it on my ipad screen i can see
it on the on your screen
um okay and this is what i wanted to
check
because if one of the e's
wouldn't have been satisfied would have
been equal zero then a random linear
combination of them
would have been zero just which
obviously has
but if it's zero with probability close
to one then
then it must be the case that all of the
eis are zero each and every one of the
many many eis
that's it this is the analysis
the pcp theorem okay
so so i'm very happy to answer questions
uh questions about the analysis uh we
started a bit late so
um and
if there are no questions about the
analysis i'll answer the question that i
was waiting to answer if i move my cross
away from the zoom window where is my
cursor
yeah but then i won't be able if i move
my closer away from the zoom
window i won't be able to show to seal
and your questions
and answer them um
but but but yes right uh let me answer
the question of is the pcp theorem
practical okay so
um okay
the piece right i showed you this this
week
it's a very simple short nice proof um
but but it's this huge huge construction
um right you need to walk much harder if
you want to
show an actual polynomial size
construction of gt low etid
and and for many years people were
saying oh it's
it's not practical because even if if
it's polynomial sizes
it's a large polynomial size um this is
no longer true i mean for
20 years we have constructions extremely
good constructions of pcp's
uh transformations where
well gt is almost linear in the size of
g we also have
nice simple cons you know relatively
simple
uh simpler proofs of the pcp theorem
um and we have kind of good
understanding
of how to prove pcp theorems so
i mean i would say that it's uh
basically practical um interestingly
what's what's actually
being used by people in security by
people in systems you know there are
people
in academia who who try to apply
those those tools
[Music]
and what they ended up using is mostly
what i showed you today
um just this this exponent
exponential size construction it still
has like a very simple
and check
and so so yes it can be used it is used
uh i i hope that it will be used even
even more
wait is the piece of ethereum used to
construct the patient proof search
no so so so the pcp theorem kicks in
when you already have a proof
and the proof is written right in
completely formal
way right you have the solution right if
it's recoloring right you have
recoloring it's very clear what the
procedure
is a proof it's written in the action
system and
and you know there is a clear procedure
to verify
if there is a proof now you can you can
go and check it very
very fast uh but it doesn't tell you
anything about how you find the proof
okay just a way to to check
um i mean i guess if you're looking for
a proof you can try
right now you have this quick way to
rule
things out
but i mean but you still need to to to
search for the proof which is all right
um what additional steps are necessary
to get to the point where pcps are
actually used to verify claim proofs
of the riemann hypothesis again so the
problem with verifying troops for the
lemon hypothesis
you need the original proof to be
written in the axiom system
completely completely rigorously right
in the axiom system
and then you can apply everything in an
automated way
no one writes proofs in the axiom system
right no mathematician
writes in such low level way
but but if you do write things in
low-level way because maybe
you use the computer to find your proof
or something
i mean then at this point you can you
can use the pcp to click quickly
okay can i ask a question also ah more
questions in the chat
yeah uh i think i may be having a hard
time keeping up but can you give a high
level summary of what we proved and how
it is related to what we wanted to show
okay let's go back to the
white words so so this is the proof
of the of the pcp theorem
right that is a transformation from
every horrible graph to
sleep whatever not like horrible means
corvo
what we showed is is this
so we showed it for quadratic equations
that it's very easy to move between
quadratic equations and three
probability
this is what theoretical computer
science did in the 70s
um and and i mean if you want to talk
about
more we can talk about it more but
but the main thing is that we didn't
show a polynomial transformation from g
to gt so what we showed is that
every right so detailed is its
exponential size and
every edge of it can be
computed in polynomial time okay which
is
which is nice which is useful uh
it's it's truly useful it is used in
every even every proof of the pcp
theorem and also
in in practice but but right it's not
it's not fully polynomial
okay so so this is this is gonna ask a
related question actually
yes which is actually sort of a question
from nike um you you mentioned the
connection between
um having a polynomial size proof and
having a
a system where you can uh generate a
single equation in o log n time
right um is there is this like an if and
only if
um and and also i guess like is there
any um other motivations for wanting to
do
to generate like a single one instead of
generating the whole proof
so okay the fact that you have
a polynomial number of local tests
which corresponds to logarithmic
randomness
i mean this is if and only if you want
the g scale to be polynomial
in the size of the fact that you can
generate
by the pcp on the some of the strongest
pcp films show how to generate
it in in poly logarithmic time i mean
for this you need to work
this is not not clear and there are
there are pcp theorems that don't
don't generate a single test in polylog
time
they generate it in for normal time they
first generate the full
gta and then you can go and pick big
edges from it
okay
um more questions
um actually dana maybe just i'm still
not sure i understand so in your
construction
e tilde is actually the collection of
all equations that can arise in your one
two three and four
okay and it's a gigantic exponential
like two to the n squared
size construction
yeah but but it's locally locally is
efficient like you can you can generate
one equation
in polynomial time in the size of the
okay let's see if i have more questions
to answer
um why is quadratic sufficient do we
need
higher all the equations so so right so
this is um
one okay quadratic is
is sufficient because you can you can
formulate
end o and not with quadratic uh with
quadratic equations
right if you want to say the end of two
things or the old two things or
cradle it's all you could it's just
quadratic
so so you can take any property any
property that you can express in logic
and and you can express it as a system
of quadratic equations
that's why quadratic equations surprise
okay so in particular right so this is
true for any
thing it it's but it's true for free
coloring it's true for any property that
you can
that you can express right this is the
cook's theorem in
in by the basis of np completeness
that that being able to express
uh uh property in in first order logic
um in in writing just so in
propositional
writing just and all not um
right this is this is equivalent to the
property being
checkable that you can formulate the
checking with with
just a logic expression
um yeah so this is why quadratic
equations are
enough we don't need higher order
equations we can
formulate higher order equations with
quadratic um
i didn't understand why only few
equations in e are
unsatisfied many more in it
are unsatisfied this is exactly what
so so so this this magic happened
um happened
in the very last part of the analysis
well
somehow we started right so in in the
intel analysis
we only know that the large fraction of
the equations are satisfied
and yet we the the the result in the end
was that a random linear combination of
all equations is satisfied with
hyperbility which means that each and
every one of the equations is satisfied
uh right so this is this kind of easy
probabilistic
claim that if you have e1 to en
and and one of them is not satisfied
even if just one of them is not
satisfied
the randomly known combination is going
to be
zero just with probability so this is
where this magic happens
all the equations should be satisfied in
e to
just many of the questions are satisfied
in it
okay wow lots of questions um
okay discuss more the equivalence of
street coloring and quadratic system
and potentially frisat
again hopefully it's clear that with
quadratic
systems you can encode end right because
n
is x1 times x2 right and if you can do
and then you can do no the note is just
one plus
x right and if you can you have end and
not then you also have or and you have
you know
full boolean logic um so now
sleek coloring right you can write
a positional formula that tells you that
right it takes a
you know those two beads it will
represent the coloring on one end and
the two beads that represent the
coloring of another end
and right you need to check that whether
they're not equal right you can write a
formula for that
right so either the first bit is is not
equal all
the second bit is not equal right
everything can be
uh describing in compositional uh
calculus and writing is a logic formula
and and enhanced as a quadratic equation
okay hopefully this this explains it
uh can a more efficient algorithm be
obtained if there is some known
structure in the provided proof
if it is decomposed into lemmas somehow
wait um are we i'm not exactly sure if
provided proof means the the the
assignment to eat
or it means my proof
that argues about 18. um
i don't know how to improve how to get a
more efficient proven than the proof
that i
showed you um
right and and and obviously getting a
more efficient construction
is kind of would be a huge
a huge uh right if we had a proof of the
full pcp theorem
that that was uh this level of
difficulty right would be great so if
you could get a more efficient
construction that's great i just don't
know how to do it
um
let's see what happens when you apply
pcp construction to problems with
obvious decisions but no known solution
finding problems like
factoring um
okay so so
notice let's go to the first whiteboard
um so so we start with with
uh checking some property um
uh here is recolorability the question
is what if i check if something is
is has a factoring or not right if i
check something easy um
or at least it has a decision and
doesn't um
i mean to check whether something is
time or not right we have a decision
procedure the issue is that if i can
distinguish between those
two efficiently then my transformation
can just you know distinguish and
understand what's the what's the answer
for for the input
and then just have two different
uh details of like constant size that
that uh one is is you know color ball
or one is is prime and one is not
primers i'm not sure what does it mean
far from time
but whatever whatever you want to map
map it to and right if you can decide
this in polynomial time
and you have you know those two constant
fixed
instances one in in in the
that is horrible actually now that i
think about it i should use
some highlighter
yes good if this property
is easy if you can distinguish between
this and this
in polynomial time then you can do it
within your polynomial time procedure
and then just have two fixed two fixed
uh
instances here and if if the answer is
this i'll put this
and if the answer is this i'll put the
other one right so everything
trivializes if you have a decision
problem
with with an efficient uh with an
efficient um
solution at least the theorem as as
as stated here trivializes
okay i mean
um good
and so this what is the resulting analog
of gtl4
factoring i don't i don't know
it's right i mean you have to map
to something well there is
local structure if you don't have local
structure
i don't right i don't even know and
what to do is there a reference filling
in the proofs of correctness of the
tests
yes so so there is a book by sanjiva
and boss
modern complexity theory i think is
called
and and i i believe that it has
the construction that i showed you today
in the book
the book is available online um
you can you can go and read it there
and i think that
this is this was the last last question
so this is it okay so thanks very much
for your talk and for your patients and
answering all our questions
uh so now we we go to a short coffee
break and you can join
a further discussion with discord and i
believe we resume in 10 minutes
okay thanks